was that buddy people are welcome to be
honest trailer commentary for men in
black one two and three I have spent a
Gilbert long Dan and it's late on a
Friday so the quicker we get this done
the quicker we can go home I tend to
feel the same way I think that I really
like the first one I've seen it many
times I've enjoyed it every time it is a
classic buddy cop movie with an
interesting premise they didn't take it
in any more interesting directions in
the sequels
yeah and there's so many interesting
places they could have taken it and
that's a huge clever world yeah and
there yeah - it's just like sex jokes
and then three is like time travel and
that was like as far as they push and
the time travel is used to just kind of
recreate the dynamic of the first one
again and to do the same [ __ ] but now
you're in the groovy pad yeah it's okay
it's fine yeah it's rolling cos Brolin
yeah bro let's go he's fun but it's not
like oh wow okay but it doesn't reach
water on sugar levels that is part of
like what hurts the sequel's is
D'Onofrio just murders it in the first
movie and no other villain can get back
Danny we're talking like you get the
feeling he lived as a bug for months
have to admire that guy like no matter
how silly the movie he's in it like he's
gonna go I I did that brush one fire
with fire where he's the bad guy and
he's a like Cajun white supremacist drug
dealer and that movie too he's just
living it he's the rest of movies
ridiculous he's under percent committed
yeah yes hon and oh yeah oh he's oh he
is he doing like the voice yes he's
doing a bob Prudhomme like true romance
the other favorite Cage another great
example who like no matter how you can
make Air Force one around him he's still
gonna give that that great performance
at the center yeah and then in the
second one when you have like Laura
Flynn Boyle just sleepwalking from scene
to scene I feel like they cut most of
her movie album and you have like Rip
Torn like they're doing like matrix
jumps or they had him like Oh picking
it's only one scene just like what if
Tommy Lee Jones in Rip Torn we're
superheroes and then we'll just yes yeah
that seemed feels like the they were
trying to compete with that run of late
90s early 2000s like the matrix move no
like that they were like here's a
reference you know like that was just
real shallow and like that seems just
like you know the matrix yeah okay we're
done it was so out of nowhere to see
these deceptive generic men in black
have special powers I don't know who's
to say should we watch it let's do it
yeah this summer we're getting honest
about summer blockbusters past and
present the area on his trailer audio
walk Buster's summer yeah
my favorite thing about these is how
many years back should I black
international and six months on cable or
on an airplane or something that's when
I'll be watching the video that started
it all and the other two that just kept
doing it like that we had the discussion
this is the proper term for plural men
in black is it men and blacks is that
men's and black sounds not we decided
that either way it sounds like the porn
parody version men's in black like
attorneys general right yeah my men is
already plural so it's a double plural
makeup
I mean it's multiple hats on many blacks
is like if the movie itself you're
referring to the title of the movie
right there's men in black one men in
black - those are the men in Black's so
mm-hmm
but those words black so John Malkovich
a Bruce Willis are the men in Reds it's
the same example I'm not talking about
Reds United States accepts refugees yeah
we get political what's up
we're not afraid to take on the big
issues in these honest trailers I had
nothing else to say clearly we don't get
that political we're I'm an SJ don't
wanna line here and there but then we're
also about to talk about goop so it's
not sure yeah yeah let's get real cold
yeah it's the culture it's what's
happening right I mean you do notice in
this movie it's very 90s and the
perspective is very nineties and like it
it doesn't necessarily link up like
today it would be hard to make a movie
about like a secret government
conspiracy that were like they were the
good guys
so they're not too many national yeah I
know but it's just cuz it's feeding off
the good but men and black international
like updates it because now it's there's
like a global deep stage like queuing on
is worldwide now baby
well it's British it's yeah what I'm
curious about them in the new movie too
is watching it back even this what's 22
year 23 years ago is how simple it would
like there
cover-up thing is just like gather
everybody in the area together and flash
them with the neuralyzer and like now
it's like with cell phones and Twitter
and social media like that everything
happens immediately in real time it's
not like you hear about anything on the
news anymore it's like you couldn't
cover this stuff up because it would all
yeah how depressing will it be if their
explanation is just the real-life
version of just call everything fake
until no one believes anything any
problem with it I get to do it like how
I'm doctor who dealt with this where
they're just like yeah people just kind
of don't care yeah like they're angry
about Game of Thrones I'm betting the
Newman in black movie they they they
build neuralyzed technology into cell
phones so that you can yeah it's like
the app that's like what do you look
like as the other gender also erases
your and that's very that's very much
like the sensibility of the series do
you like I can actually see them making
that jug like everybody's always like I
did this over just flashy think I'm
there mmm selfies do it yeah crack this
question
bring em in black for turn national
keeps on enjoying the men in black
Galaxy defenders
they're agents who operate with no
accountability what branch of government
do we report sir for none keep everyone
under surveillance top secret prisons
and beat the aliens they police within
an inch of their lives so it's a
screwball comedy about the deep state
only in the 90s computer internet land
of a-holes
some of these a-holes are aliens who get
to live undercover as major celebrities
everyone on those cranes is an alias
what about that position
FLAC recognize I've forgotten that
Michael Jensen had a cameo as himself as
this is what never been it like maybe
the second one yeah I was that the
second one is that a pretty big get at
that boy yeah it was definitely yeah
yeah I think it may have been like Oh -
actually yeah I was gonna say 2001-2002
something like that yeah no he was still
like a huge star who doesn't just cameo
and like anything yeah but yeah was I
remember as a genuine surprise when he
showed us second question since the
video scream is set in space on a
spaceship does that make scream cannon
to men in black yes yes it does and then
I'm happy
just like how the remember the time
video is cannon for gods of Egypt Murphy
at least convincing onscreen kiss he's
Michael Jackson Iman also had to kiss
William Shatner and uh also very good I
think it might mean I've just been good
at riddles and then in these movies as
we might see later Lara Flynn Boyle had
to lick Tommy Lee Jones our video for
her CG here is keep going
ethnic stereotypes Mikey or yeah it's
really just one of those two they'll
that's never start with agents J and K
or at Lee by an increasingly happy Tommy
Lee Jones and Will Smith at the height
plateau and depth of his powers
[Music]
okay well for the scene think about how
you just start in seven pounds where K
shows J the ropes while being hunted by
a villain who can kill people instantly
unless you're the heroes as they search
for an all-powerful device that was
right under their nose all along the
second one where J shows K the robes
while being hunted by a villain who can
kill people instantly unless you're the
heroes as they search for an
all-powerful device that was right under
their nose all along but and the light
and the third would where J goes back in
time so k the walls while being hunted
by a villain who can kill people
instantly unless you're the heroes we
want more sequels to this thing I don't
ask questions I don't want to know the
answer to I'm really I think that's the
big thing that undermines the whole
franchise is they were so merry to this
formula like everything the first movie
does they feel like they had to do and
the others and like you don't nobody
would care you're always on earth you're
it's always about a little thing and
it's find a little thing and it's with
someone you already know yeah and it's
always like oh I need a new partner or
my partner just left we gotta go find my
old partner it's like just come up with
a new original concept you've got aliens
on earth and I feel like there's an I
know we were just making the joke about
like the social commentary and blah blah
blah but I do feel like there's enough
if you just if you can skirt that line
of exploring the idea of agency that
police's refugees in space and still
make it a men and black movie mmm-hmm I
think like I mean they they do it well
enough in the first one like I feel like
there's stuff to explore there what if
they have to go to a nice place
they just clearly don't care about that
stuff and they're making a comedy which
is fine but it's there
yeah it'd be cool to do more with it
like they're also so inconsistent from
film to film about so many things of
like how the world works and are the men
in black like are they the best of the
best are they elite or are they just the
renovation punches dollar yeah like
that's war but in the second one like
you know well semester was like they
recruited him because he kept like a
foot race with an alien and you know
like off-the-charts and thinking and
into it like the thing in the scene was
just like I shot the girl cause she has
quantum physics like thing and then like
magic words like to fight but they're
like why do you want to do this those
Marines like so you'll just take the
period his career where he was only
allowed to play David puddy movies are
basically like if you did three ace
Ventura's and it's the first one is do
not go in there the second one is
definitely don't go in there was no
minute your calls yeah and then the
third one is do not go in there but then
he's obviously on a green screen yeah I
mean the movies still like they mad like
three at least works because it is fun
to watch Will Smith do his thing against
Josh Brolin in this case like it's it's
a formula that works but give us
something new right let's break the
enemy maybe maybe this fourth one they
are gonna finally break the pattern
although it kind of doesn't look like it
looks like they're doing one's a newbie
the other one train a new partner while
you're investigating and worldwide
threat ed Laden you were talking about
this it's like are we supposed to think
it's exotic that this alien franchise
has gone - whoa - they reveal that the
entire earth is inside like a lager and
an alien train station do things a
little differently the first the first
one ended with like the the
soul-crushing issue that were a ball in
a pool table we're a marble yes sorry
yeah where's Lana in a locker on a
planet in a galaxy is marble and a
marble but we call elevators lips
Piccadilly sir
[Laughter]
jokes like the one where you go there's
a lot of pocket dimension right we're in
one on the thing we're also in a locker
also we are and that was a walker of a
citrate also an alumnus that states like
the right there's we're lockers all the
way down yes universe of lockers what's
up with all this tea that big Locker is
inside our galaxy which is also inside a
marble be I played that ever being
played with this applies amazing but in
England the steering wheels mighty
spilling it's like all said Kingsman was
in England and they're like what do we
do for the sequel I guess they gotta go
to a man just have to go back and forth
from here there are closest allies
franchise your relationship crossing
each other across the Atlantic anyway
tomorrow
to just go to England there's other
countries all right all right keep going
thank you ask how many ribs could have
Will Smith ribs since a wheel Smith
favorite thanks he never appreciated you
anywhere how would I feel somebody come
running it there's so many riffs
yeah he just that's that's you know yeah
I do like I wish the the the bonus thing
for the men in black trilogy on the DVD
value pack or whatever was just behind
the scenes of extended Will Smith rib I
mean I wasn't in every single movie he's
in yeah every single movie well not all
pounds all the comedies though yeah well
the comedy it's just like wills bit yeah
riffs no he's a funny guy anybody saying
Will Smith is funny in you know it got
it they just lean on it yeah they lean
on it a lot I mean a lot of these like I
always wonder when they start to like
how much of it was scripted cuz some of
these feel like they were definitely in
the script and others feel like they
were definitely at the camera
yeah wonderfully guys like him and Will
Ferrell like look at a script in the
moment they get to a page that's like
will or one of the wills goes crazy and
they're just like to save another
picture no I think it's more like they
get a script and then they cross out
just whatever anybody wrote for that
their brother whatever Jayden think
about Christopher Walken goes through
scripts and gets rid of all the
punctuation yeah that's why he talks the
the way he talks yeah good times
yeah I keep going he's an alien so flash
back to an era when summer movies were
more than
Phil they dominate small pop culture
with their own toys tie-in sunglasses
video games cartoon series and of course
smash hit rap singles from the star over
the credits with some big wagon taken
down a moderate hit rap single for the
sequel don't call that one
diminishing returns like that kind of
sums up the whole franchise story the
grobart made that yeah no country for
old spacemen snakes in a day jackass -
what'd he choose in the shadows zeds
dead baby zeds dead papa roach
[Music]
guardians of the galaxy yes that's what
they do look out oh man he killed your
dad if only he had some gonna time
machine in your pocket you have a time
machine in your pocket so dumb cuz also
like the movie it's all about time
travel and there's always problems but
the very glaring one is that Tommy Lee
Jones gets erased from time and Will
Smith is still a Mendon black eye being
my agent and it's like he would
immediately go back to being a cop
Spencer creates a separate timeline no
it doesn't unless the explanation is
that someone else recruited him yes they
would be talking about they would not
know who he is because he would never
been recruited because right yeah you
can't have it both ways unless it's like
Back to the Future they come up with
something with their like there's a
localized distortion they're protected
Jennifer from the effects of the
whatever before I get to cut the weeds
let's see some deleted there's the only
cops in the galaxy I think blue lives
don't better just want to say yeah we
get political yeah what's up we choose
to power what about that I'm an sjw yeah
wait a minute
more like nobody's ever made that yeah
it's too bad screen cookies never come
with my dummy accounts all of these out
before we move over to the main channel
because it's just
it's better now whatever I was about to
say I'm not gonna say that's fair
story welcome to earth
The Fresh Prince of nowhere I make this
movie look good sir I don't care for
retirement Flynn Boyle rules
why you little
Tiffany deserve to die this guy's actual
name is ripped or we possibly can a
grower not a show word you head explode
- no stronzo
a dog's journey through space and wild
wild past while pests
based on us a JK probably I just throw a
lot of these it's gonna replace CDs soon
that's just a smaller CD i think the
aliens are messing with you but they had
the pause they had those mini business
this came at little cds inside of the
cartridge yeah they're cities in a
floppy just a worse CD if you were gonna
show somebody the music player of the
future it'd be an mp3 player that wasn't
that far out we should maybe just yeah
this is bad but I'm saying an mp3 player
was like 10 years away so that would be
what aliens would be like this will be
your future yeah but if I if I was able
to come up with an mp3 player for my
comedy script then I should like stop
writing and like done that done that
yeah well you wouldn't have to insane
like what if you had a little I'm just
saying in the reality of the movie
aliens are messy yes it's not the most
I'm just imaginative future tech is the
thing we have but smaller what are the
guns were small we have anything else
that it keep going hey wait a second
isn't that the alien that agent case
shoots and kills in the movies opening
scene yeah well I guess the video is a
prequel then and also pretty dark kills
him after that
the font music you are we sure Tim
Burton didn't make the first one this is
a very Burton name yeah Barry Sonnenfeld
the director of this also did the Addams
Family movies which are also quite
burdening but also quite burdening yeah
and these are severed hands yeah so I
guess yeah that's my takeaway is group
maybe they should have given this
franchise to someone else for the second
at the rental I could give a Guillermo
del Toro a shot at a men in black camera
the Toro would make a cambered shot at a
man in black give Christopher Nolan a
man but he wears suits he's hilarious
conception is kind of an advice yeah
think about it guys in suits they show
up they mess with your brain you wake up
thinking something different yeah had a
great rap song featuring Leonardo
DiCaprio because we grew up with it so
it seems so normal to us but the concept
of an a-list movie star who also
provides the soundtrack for his own film
I know right that's it's very odd and
not complete there has to have been a
handful of times that's happened in the
90s like The Bodyguard Eastwood tinkles
on the piano you know just random Keys
song that described the plot had been a
thing but then it's Will Smith came in
it was like no really I'm going to do it
yeah really history robbed us of one for
independence today okay yeah when they
were edits yeah when the credits start i
have not seen a lot but I've heard about
this with a credit star for Aladdin the
first thing you hear is dj khaled like
yeah dj khaled we the best music like
that's how the credits start and then
Will Smith raps over a beat that's like
a friend like me but it's like a rap
beat and it isn't describing Aladdin yes
okay good good come
I'm in I'll say it will smith i like to
miss the genie uh-huh controversial
opinion may not be i don't know i don't
know what people think in the movie is
there like a language barrier for me
where like i just hear him saying DJ
cali over and over again but other
people are hearing him say a lot of
different words and now he only actual
sentences just says DJ khaled and then
we the best music which best i don't
even know what that means we major major
key i just you know he does production
he's the guy making the most I know that
but yeah we've got a sign your it's like
signing the portal says another one
another one
I think Will Smith doesn't he kind of
doesn't work with good directors man
like he doesn't you never see him paired
with like anyone bigger than him or
anyone who could tell him what to do
start saying they want to be the main
voice behind it so a director who also
wants to be the main voice by the movie
doesn't want to work with Will Smith
because it's like then there's gonna be
this conflict of who say this is why
it's so great that Tom Cruise has found
Christopher McQuarrie and they like
gonna work together sure but I do want
that moment on set where wills just like
how about that we just keep rolling on
this one and I just riff for a while and
Christopher Nolan's like riff no he just
this thing just looks at Jonathan Nolan
if you have no not this time because I'd
like to see him and better better stuff
yeah he hasn't had a good movie in in
decades like a good movie not something
you enjoyed but like a critically
acclaimed just like good ass Wilson ask
Will Smith movie pursue happy that was
gotta be one more cop orkut room I was
not a big no-no when the cops was an
organ it's not a huge
our universe but there were just orcs
for someone that has like a very like
deliberate way of choosing projects and
he does it's like all in some like
cross-referenced binder you can look it
up he's got some weird criteria that he
looks for in every movie it's not doing
so well there is one there's got to be I
mean you're maybe he messed up a an
equation in a spreadsheet you know when
you screw up one number and it'll work
really closely worked out careful
process leads you to selecting after
earth the changeable yes it was more
than a selection after Earth you can
look into the hopes that were pinned on
that movie they had an entire social
network plan that is gonna be about like
year after Earth fursona that you could
talk to people through video games theme
parks ghosts learn to get Sony hype they
created like a world upon a world upon
world of cinematic universe after Earth
things have you seen a Winter's Tale as
anyone at this table is please
it is baffling and insane and he shows
up in one scene as the devil okay not a
sports so I found a lot of interesting
words like a huge smash critical hit it
stars Colin Farrell and Russell Crowe
also both giving insane performances
that make no sense but Will Smith is one
scene a Satan really worth checking out
definitely check that out and come back
next week for our honest trailer then oh
man
you can say there's just a lot going on
it's a lot going on you know I don't
even know it's some blow friends in high
places
yeah so we'll be back next week lanzhou
ban me have a good weekend see that
another one
[Music]
you